Let's say that we want to
take 14 and divide it by 70.
So clearly this is going
to be a number less than 1.
14 is clearly less than
70, but let's try to do it.
So immediately we say, OK,
70 goes into 1 zero times,
so that's not going to work out.
70 goes into 14-- well, it
doesn't go into 14 any time.
So we're going to have to
add some decimal places.
So let's do that.
Let's add a decimal
place right over here.
Make sure we put the
decimal right over there.
But now we can think of it as
70 goes into 140 how many times.
Well, 70 goes into 14 two times.
And 2 times 70 is 140.
And you subtract, and you
are left with no remainder.
So you're done.
You can write that 14 divided
by 70 is exactly equal to 0.2.
Let's do a slightly more
involved example, like this.
So let's say I wanted to
divide-- oh, I don't know.
Let's do a little
more interesting.
Let's divide 16.
Let's divide 16
by-- I don't know.
Let's divide it by 25
and see what we get.
So initially we say, OK,
25 doesn't go into 1.
It doesn't go into 16.
We're going to have to add
some decimals right over here.
How many times does
25 go into 160?
And make sure we put
the decimal above it.
So let's see, 25 times 4 is 100.
25 times 6 is 150,
so that looks right.
So it goes six times.
6 times 25 is 120
plus 30, which is 150.
And now we can subtract.
And 160 minus 150 is 10.
And now we just bring
down one more 0.
We add one more place value.
Notice we're not
changing the value.
16 is the same thing as
16.0, which is the same thing
as 16.00.
So now you bring down
this 0 right over here.
And how many times
does 25 go into 100?
Well, we know it goes
exactly four times.
4 times 25 is 100,
and we are done.
We have nothing left
to keep dividing with,
so we can say that 16 divided
by 25 is equal to 0.64.